bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regardez en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir est
une journaliste engagée figure de la
droite conservatrice et passionnée par
le débat d'idée bonsoir Jenny Bastié
bonsoir et merci d'être là vous voulez
cette fois sauver la différence des
sexes c'est le titre de votre cours et
sec qui vient de paraître dans la
collection tracts chez Gallimard une
différence menacée d'effacement
dites-vous et qui pourrait même nous
mener à la guerre des sexes bigra on a
besoin d'en parler et ce sera tout à
l'heure dans la deuxième partie mais on
commence avec la gauche façon puzzle
c'est aujourd'hui que Martine Froget la
dissidence du PS élu de l'Ariège a fait
son entrée dans l'hémicycle l'occasion
de s'interroger ce soir sur la nuque
l'alliance à l'Assemblée entre les
insoumis les socialistes les écologistes
et les communistes d'une alliance plus
fragile qu'il y a un an un chef Jean-Luc
Mélenchon contesté alors la nuque
est-elle dépassée grand débat dans un
instant sur ce plateau avec nos invités
avant de retrouver à 20h15 les partis
pris de nos affranchis et puis Bourbon
Express bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu génie
Bastié vous le suivez dans le plaisir
[Musique]
qu'il est loin le temps ou la nuque
affichait glorieusement son unité depuis
début avril l'alliance électorale de la
gauche à l'Assemblée n'en finit pas de
diviser Fabien Roussel cette offert un
nouveau clash avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce
week-end Bernard Cazeneuve en rupture
avec le PS tire à vue sur le premier
secrétaire Olivier Faure et la victoire
de la dissidente socialiste Martine
Froget dans l'Ariège contre l'insomnie
rebat les cartes sur l'avenir électoral
de la nuque bonsoir Daniel au Bono nupes
il faut dire je crois c'est mieux que la
nuque vous dites comme vous voulez merci
d'être avec nous député insoumise de
Paris le groupe et les filles qui a
décidé à la majorité de réintégrer
Adrien cadenas au sein de sa famille
politique à l'Assemblée ce qui n'est pas
du goût des autres partenaires de la
nuque on en dira un mot tout à l'heure
bonsoir et marafovic bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes la présidente des jeunes
socialistes sur la ligne d'Olivier Faure
le patron du PS qui a été réélu au terme
d'un congrès difficile qui a coupé en
deux les militants
reviendra entre pro Nupe et anti-up
bonsoir Olivier Pérou bienvenue vous
êtes journaliste politique à L'Express
en charge du suivi de la gauche c'est
d'ailleurs dans vos colonnes que Fabien
Roussel a lancé les hostilités contre
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avant d'être lui au
Lama ce weekend à la tête du parti
communiste autopsie du cadavre comment
meurt le Parti socialiste chez Fayard
est toujours dans les bonnes de
librairies enfin bonsoir Antoine
Bristiel bienvenue vous êtes chercheur à
Sciences Po professeur agrégé de
sciences sociales et directeur de
l'observatoire de l'opinion à la
Fondation Jean Jaurès Eugénie Bastié je
suis sûr que vous regardez les débats
idéologiques à gauche et de très près
donc n'hésitez pas à intervenir quand
vous le souhaitez on commence par
planter le décor avec la mi Stéphane
blackovski pourquoi rien ne va plus au
sein de cette nouvelle alliance il a 200
secondes pas une de plus c'est le chrono
de lacos c'est parti
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir cher Stéphane bonsoir
bonsoir à toutes et tous alors comment
va la nuque alors la nuque c'est un peu
tendu en ce moment faut dire ce qui est
d'ailleurs j'étais devant LCP qui
diffusait en exclusivité les premiers
mystique je me dis peut-être qu'il y
aura du chalut peut-être qu'elle va être
je sais pas même s'il fait pas du tout
tant mieux d'ailleurs mais si on pense à
ça que c'est que c'est un peu électrique
que cette élection de Martine Froget
parce que le problème c'est que Martin
projet
elle est socialiste depuis 30 ans donc
elle voudrait si j'ai avec les
socialiste jusque là tout va bien oui
mais elle ne veut pas siéger avec la
nups d'où la question peut-on être Ops
sans être à la nupaisse Martine projet
elle pense que oui elle va chercher à
convaincre Boris Vallot demain de
l'accueillir
dans le groupe des socialistes on écoute
son argument
moi je lui proposais de faire un groupe
plus ouvert en tout cas et surtout de
pas être soumis aux insoumis quoi parce
que c'est quand même ça un peu ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui sur la nupes quoi et
c'est ce que j'aurais pu dans cet accord
alors les députés socialistes vont-ils
lui ouvrir les bras ça demande réflexion
il faut quand même un peu réfléchir
avant de prendre une décision mais
pendant que les socialistes
réfléchissent Mathilde panot elle a
tranché en l'écoute je ne suis pas
d'accord pour que une députée qui a fait
battre une députée de l'intergroupe de
la nupette siège dans le groupe
socialiste c'est je suis sûr que
beaucoup des socialistes seront d'accord
avec moi sur cette question et les
présidente du groupe insoumis vous voyez
mes bons quand même on sent qu'elle a la
prend presque l'intention de forcer un
peu la décision des socialistes mais
c'est pas si simple parce que s'il y a
beaucoup de sujets qui divisent les
socialistes mais si un sujet qui les
divise particulièrement c'est c'est
justement celui de l'adhésion et les
filles de l'alliance avec les filtres au
sein de la nupesse je vous rappelle que
lors du congrès Nicolas Mayer rossignol
qui lui était contre cette alliance avec
les filles venu quasiment autant de voix
qu'Olivier Faure qui lui était Bourbon
en attendant à ça peut-être même un peu
moins c'est l'huile patron et donc il a
appris position sans marquer le projet
en disant non elle ne doit pas siéger
avec les députés sauf que lui il est pas
député est-ce que vous croyez que ce que
dit Olivier force a impressionne Valérie
rabot non je ne crois pas
le communiqué ahurissant et scandaleux
de la direction du Parti socialiste qui
n'a pas de légitimité pour faire un tel
communiqué quand on fait à peu près 50%
des voix on n'a pas de légitimité pour
engager ainsi partis
du PS donc évidemment on voit bien que
c'est compliqué donc faut dire que ce
qu'apprence qui maintenait un petit peu
de discipline dans cette nupes notamment
de la part des écolos des communistes
des socialistes c'est que ils avaient
besoin de les filles pour gagner des
élections sinon ils étaient moins de
disparaître or ce week-end il se trouve
que dans l'Ariège la candidate elle est
fille elle a été battue donc si on salit
avec un défi pour gagner des élections
qui les perdent je veux dire ça pose des
questions comme en France en tout cas
lui Fabien Roussel s'interroge il a
donné une interview à L'Express parlait
à Olivier Perroud il a lâché un mot
cette alliance elle est dépassée en
bravo Olivier parce que c'était vraiment
quelque chose qui était repris dans leur
ensemble de la presse qui sont les
données à courjois donc manuel Bompard
il a cherché un petit peu
demander par dessus la tête de Roussel
et vous les adhérents du PC vous en
pensez quoi alors ça tombait bien il y
avait un congrès ce weekend donc il y
avait Fabien Roussel qui a pu parler et
il y avait aussi les communistes
rassemblés autour de lui on écoute la
réponse à Manuel Bompard
je le dis clairement et en toute
fraternité mais les vous de vos affaires
forcément c'est réglé parce qu'il y
avait 20 secondes comme ça
d'applaudissement derrière donc le
soutien était massif je vous ai pas tout
diffusé bon vous avez compris que quand
ils avaient besoin les filles les alliés
de la nuit pèse de les filles étaient
prêts à faire des accommodements pour
avoir leur place à l'Assemblée mais ça
c'était avant puisque maintenant quand
elle est fibre renouer l'alliance comme
par exemple manuel Bompard a proposé
plusieurs fois mais vraiment plusieurs
fois au verre de faire une alliance avec
eux pour les européennes un moment
marine tondulé était agacé
quand c'est non c'est non faut arrêter
de faire les forceurs en fait on l'a dit
on la redit on la redit maintenant stop
on discute quand ils veulent de plein de
choses
et non c'est la dernière fois que je le
dis je pense que maintenant c'est clair
pour tout le monde c'est un peu tendu
comme vous disiez vraiment super cool la
nuit pêche une très très belle dynamique
électorale il y avait quelque chose de
très réussi au moment des législatives
mais maintenant j'ai l'impression que la
pression qui permettait de mettre un peu
tout le monde ou pas a disparu alors
comment ils vont rester unique ça je
sais pas en tout cas merci merci
beaucoup Stéphane je vais commencer avec
les observateurs si vous voulez bien
pour qu'on essaie de se figurer les
choses Olivier Perroud sur une échelle
de 1 à 10 comment va la nipples
c'est dur de donner un chiffre précis on
va dire 5 allez je vais pas mouiller je
vais faire une réponse de Normands
connaissez l'adage l'Union est un est un
combat si on se plonge un peu dans
l'histoire ce qui s'est passé pour
l'union de la gauche entre 1971 et 1980
ça a été très chaotique
en tout cas force cette constaté
aujourd'hui qu'on parle de la gauche
un moment on parle de la gauche c'est ça
c'est un peu ça je je vous ramène à ce
qui se passait pendant l'élection
présidentielle où on avait des images
d'armement de bourg en train de
téléphoner de Daniel algo nous disons je
vais je vais participer à la primaire
qui peut à la primaire Olivier Olivier
Ford désertant la campagne quelque chose
il se passe quelque chose c'est déjà ça
néanmoins alors il y a un problème
majeur aujourd'hui dans la nups et se
promène majeur c'est la crise d'égo il y
en a trop des égaux dans l'anus et de
fait il y a celui de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il y a celui de famille Roussel il y a
celui d'Olivier fort il y a celui de
Bernard Cazeneuve beaucoup d'hommes
voilà non mais en tout cas il y a
aujourd'hui à gauche et globalement dans
la nuque il y a une crise d'égo et le
souci c'est qu'on en oublie de
travailler sur le fond pendant
la petite séquence qu'on vient d'avoir
là on nous disait justement que le le le
la nuque c'est une réussite mais quand
on regarde dans le détail les 151
circonscriptions elles sont
historiquement
circonscription plus ou moins de gauche
quand on parle de l'Ariège l'Ariège
c'est de gauche depuis la période de la
SFIO donc il y a pas vraiment de
surprise elle a été une surprise hors du
PS il peut y avoir deux candidats au
législatives et bien sûr ça a été une
surprise à deux titres d'une part parce
que la gauche gagnait enfin la gauche
revivait sur ses marges donc les marges
les plus radicales celles de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et que le PS disparaissait
était sauvé par et la deuxième c'est
qu'elle ne se disputait plus elle
arrivait à à faire une coalition un
accord électoral mais le fond du
problème aujourd'hui il y en a plus ou
moins quelques-uns qui le mettent sur le
sujet et pour se Balou chez les
socialistes je pense notamment à lui ou
à François Ruffin chez les insoumis
c'est la question de de d'ouvrir
d'élargir cette électorat et notamment
l'électorat des classes populaires
ouvrières dans le Nord qui sont
aujourd'hui beaucoup passés chez Marine
Le Pen et il y a aussi l'autre électorat
le suivi de centre gauche qui a voté
avec avec foi pour emman Macron en 2017
et qui aujourd'hui ne veut pas donc il y
a tout un travail à refaire aujourd'hui
et qui n'est pas fait pourquoi parce que
voilà on est dans séquence c'est moi qui
est la clé parce que je suis insoumis et
que j'ai gagné et j'ai dû arriver en
premier c'est moi parce que je suis
socialiste donc j'ai une espèce d'Oran
naturel je sais pas parce que je suis
écologiste et que le temps était
écologiste ça marche pas
assez de travail il y a pas un problème
de ligne quand même entre une Brussel on
voit que les critiques elle fusent de
tous les partenaires soumis communistes
socialiste aussi alors pas forcément on
va dire de la nuque mais canal
historique c'est un problème d'homme ou
c'est un problème de ligne politique
aujourd'hui c'est fracture c'est pas un
problème de ligne politique j'aurais
tendance à vous dire justement c'est que
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure vous disiez le
la nups c'était mieux il y a un an que
que maintenant la nuit pèse il y a un
nom ça existe pas encore c'est quand
même une coalition qui est née en
l'espace de quelques jours alors qui
était largement demandé depuis
extrêmement longtemps par l'ensemble des
électeurs de gauche des personnes qui se
positionnaient à gauche et qui a réussi
à être construite en espèces de quelques
jours
pas seulement avec un nombre extrêmement
conséquent de propositions à l'intérieur
de de cette coalition électorale ce qui
montre bien qu'il y avait une certaine
cohérence en termes idéologique dans
cette dans cet espace là et qui n'était
pas seulement une coalition de
circonstances et d'ailleurs quand on
regarde et c'est ce qu'on avait fait à
la Fondation Jean Jaurès le les valeurs
des personnes qui se considèrent proche
des différents partis de la nups alors
que
ELV EPS et LFI on voit qu'il y a une
vraie cohérence à l'intérieur de ces
parties là vous pouvez avoir certains
points de désaccord comme sur les
questions européennes ou ce genre sur le
nucléaire par exemple mais globalement
il y a une vraie cohérence idéologique à
l'intérieur de cet espace là donc les
divisions on en fait trop les
journalistes elles sont un peu
superficielles
sur les questions sur les questions de
fond néanmoins là où il y a une vraie
divergence c'est sur le l'aspect
stratégique des choses c'est que là vous
voyez que il y a une culture qui est
beaucoup plus dans la conflictualité au
sein des proches de LFI et qui est
beaucoup plus dans le compromis chez les
proches du parti spécialiste et d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts et notamment dans
l'attitude qu'il faut avoir par rapport
au reste des autres partis politiques et
notamment à l'Assemblée nationale là
vous voyez que vous pouvez avoir des
lignes de tension qui apparaissent mais
c'est pas des lignes de tension
qui sont vraiment sur les valeurs où
vous auriez des lignes des lignes
complètement différentes alors après
vous pouvez avoir des personnes qui sont
à l'extérieur de la de la nups comme
Bernard Cazeneuve qui ont là un vrai
positionnement qui est complètement
différent mais néanmoins à l'intérieur
de cette espèce de la nups vous avez pas
forcément de de choses aussi différentes
que cela et pourtant alors que vous avez
un boulevard vous allez me voir venir
c'est la ligne de libération
ce matin gauche à la rue malgré le
boulevard c'est vrai en pleine crise des
retraites vous avez tout pour
capitaliser le travail c'est un thème de
gauche et on voit bien dans les sondages
que c'est pas si évident que ça la faute
à qui la faute à quoi Daniel Baudot déjà
je voudrais rappeler que dans un moment
vous l'avez dit de grande mobilisations
sociales nous sommes engagés dans cette
bataille et toutes d'accord il y a une
unité syndicale mais il y a aussi une
unité politique sur le fond et voilà ça
c'est pas rien nous avons fait
énormément de meeting en commun nous
avons défendu les mêmes propositions les
mêmes revendications à l'Assemblée
nationale avec des modalités différentes
certes mais globalement et c'est le
constat qu'on faisait tous et toutes
lors de notre séminaire d'intervenu pèse
qui a lieu la semaine dernière il y
avait voilà une analyse de la situation
et de perspective commune et ça c'est
pas rien parce que pour nous en tout cas
la France insoumise ce qui unit pour
nous et ce qui fait d'ailleurs c'est
l'action l'action les électeurs ça
compte aussi il y a des sondages certes
un peu tôt et là vous l'avez vu si
l'élection présidentielle avait lieu
demain Jean-Luc Mélenchon perdrait trois
points même un peu plus trois points et
demi près de 4.18 et demi au lieu de 22
c'est c'est le problème Mélenchon qui
est à l'origine des divisions où c'est
trop
caricatural on peut lire ça comme ça
c'est un peu réducteur pour le coup et
on peut lire les choses différentes
manières parce que les 22 c'est le point
d'arrivée de la présidentielle au départ
c'était pas 22 c'était bien moins que ça
donc faut voir aussi le moment c'est pas
que c'est bien parce que un sondage à 4
ans de l'échéance c'est c'est vraiment
voilà ça peut donner l'air du temps mais
l'air du temps il change et la dynamique
d'une campagne change les choses et on
l'a défile dans la rue marine le Pennel
engrange et on va dans les enquêtes
c'est vrai que et c'est un problème pour
nous mais je pense que pour tout le camp
républicain pour le coup il y a un choix
politique qui est fait de des diaboliser
Marine Le Pen et de diaboliser la nuit
pêche et les insoumis et je pense que
les propos tenus par plusieurs figures
de la macronie l'ont montré à une
certaine étape et vous remarquerez que
malgré cela malgré la diabolisation de
la nipples à travers les filles et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon malgré ça nous
apparaisons quand même quand on fait le
total de la news comme la principale
opposition donc oui je dis pas que c'est
simple je ne sais pas si on n'a jamais
eu un boulevard franchement moi pas
l'impression depuis plus de 10 ans que
que je suis engagée dans ce dans cette
dynamique de la France insoumise qu'on
nous est jamais laissé un boulevard je
pense qu'on est allé le chercher on a
déblayer le terrain et qu'on sait le
faire on le sait le faire dans la lutte
et dans les mobilisations et c'est quand
même le moment il y a des électeurs
projets par exemple on sait le faire
aussi dans les dynamiques électorales
parce que je finis là-dessus alors on
parlera de du cas de l'Ariège mais tout
de même la dynamique de laupes elle a
fait progresser de dizaines et de
dizaines de sièges alors peut-être
qu'ils étaient historiquement à gauche
mais on les avait perdu
et donc cette dynamique là aussi je
crois que on va la tester on l'a vu à
l'échelle de des législatives et moi je
ne désespère pas qu'on continue à
construire cette dynamique là dans les
prochaines échéances parce que je crois
que elle est portée d'espoir
30 ans au Parti socialiste en général
les dissidents qui gagnent sont
réintégrés c'est vraiment la la culture
de beaucoup de parties y compris le PS
pourquoi vous voulez pas qu'elle siège
Martine Froget non mais pour le coup moi
ce que vous le souhaitez d'un conduit
peut-être national je trouve qu'on peut
pas attirer des conclusions nationales
d'une élection locale dans une
circonscription qui est historique mais
d'abord sur le groupe
c'est une camarade que j'ai déjà croisé
en plus sur le terrain j'étais allé
défendre le texte orientation de
l'olivier fort en Ariège il y a quelques
mois moi ce que je pense c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le Parti socialiste n'est
pas celui qu'il était il y a un an un an
et demi et c'est d'ailleurs bienvenu le
Parti socialiste est aujourd'hui un
parti qui est engagé dans l'union de la
gauche qui est engagée dans
l'intergroupe nupestre dans le nom du
groupe et je pense que Olivier Faure que
Boris Vallot sont très claires alors que
aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas être engagé au groupe
socialiste à l'Assemblée nationale sans
accepter le nom entier de ce groupe
c'est-à-dire membre soumis aux insoumis
moi je ne suis pas je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ça et puis d'ailleurs
c'est la majorité des militants
socialistes ne sont pas d'accord avec ça
non plus et je pense surtout que au-delà
des militants au delà des adhérents ce
qui compte c'est ce que le peuple de
gauche attend de nous et ce que le
peuple de gauche attend de nous
aujourd'hui c'est un camp de gauche
mobilisé dans la bataille pour le
retrait de la réforme des retraites et
je ne sais pas si je rejoins la question
de la bataille des ego qu'Olivier Pérou
évoquait évoquait tout à l'heure mais ce
que je crois en effet c'est qu'il faut
parfois peut-être un peu se décentrer de
ces petits nombrils pour regarder ce qui
se passe dans le pays j'entends quand
même que vous jeunes socialiste vous
vous dites la portée ouverte à Martine
projet si vous avez un mot une voie je
pense plutôt une ouverture ce que je
crois en tout cas c'est que pour être
aujourd'hui au sein du groupe socialiste
il faut en accepter l'ensemble des
règles donc c'est quand même non mais
ce que je crois c'est à elle de se
positionner et son positionnement me
semble clair et je le regrette bien les
universités non j'admire du coup le
respect des règles à l'intérieur de la
nups qui sont vraiment un respect des
règles qui se sont eux-mêmes établies
mais je ne souligne tout de même je
compte le contraste entre la souplesse
envers 4 nains qui lui a le droit de
réintégrer le groupe malgré ses phrases
et la rigidité qu'on a face à Martine
projet je note juste ce qu'on appelle ce
qui me paraît assez assez étonnant on va
dire une transition parfaite puisque
justement Adrien catenin pourrait-il
faire exploser la nuque c'est une des
questions qui se pose à travers ce sujet
puisque à la majorité les insoumis ont
décidé de le réintégrer après sa
condamnation pour violence conjugale et
clivage ne date pas d'hier on le voit à
l'Assemblée sur certaines réformes le
nucléaire ou les énergies renouvelables
regardez autour d'horizon signe Marco
pommier
Adrien catenin réintégrer au groupe la
France insoumise après en avoir été
suspendu ce matin les insoumis ont voté
en faveur de son retour 4 mois après sa
condamnation pour violence conjugale une
décision qui sème la discorde si Adrien
avait été député socialiste et non pas
insoumis il n'aurait pas été réintégré
l'affaire catenans a empoisonné les
relations au sein de la nupes la
coalition de la gauche bien divisée
aussi sur sa stratégie parlementaire les
insoumis défendent une logique de
conflit loin de faire l'unanimité
certains dérapages contre le ministre du
Travail Olivier du soft ont choqué vous
êtes un imposteur et un assassin je
tiens à dire à quel point
nous sommes choqués par les propos qui
ont été tenus et j'ajouterai
tenir de tels est absolument
inacceptable des divergences
stratégiques qui éclatent au grand jour
en pleine bataille contre la réforme des
retraites socialiste écologistes et
communiste retire leurs amendements par
centaines pour aller plus vite et des
battre de l'article 7 article phare qui
reporte l'âge légal à 64 ans une
stratégie fustigée par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon incompréhensible retrait des
amendements du Parti communiste le reste
de la loi ne compte pas hâte de se faire
battre un tweet aux allures de rappel à
l'ordre jusqu'au bout les insoumis
joueront la carte de l'obstruction de
quoi agacer leurs alliés tous les cas il
y a eu une volonté de s'imposer ça signe
un peu la fin d'un acte 1 de la nuit
Pesse qui a fonctionné jusqu'à présent
qui était issu de l'élection
présidentielle et que maintenant nous
passons nous devons passer à un acte 2
une volonté restée vaine alors que les
désaccords persistent sur le nucléaire
mi-mars les communistes ont voté pour la
relance de la à l'inverse du reste de la
gauche
Olivier perron au fond la fracture elle
se joue davantage sur la manière c'est
ça de s'opposer notamment on l'a vu
pendant le débat sur les retraites c'est
ça le point le clivage le plus important
non je pense que le point de clivage le
plus important au sein de la nups qui on
le rappelle est un groupe un intergroupe
de députés pas parti politique ou enfin
ça ne dépasse pas les murs de
l'Assemblée techniquement en tout cas
aujourd'hui on l'a pas vraiment vu le
point de clivage le plus important il a
un angle s'appelle Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça
c'est voilà il a montré en un tweet on
l'a vu avec ce tweet dans le débat la
force de la nuque depuis juin était
justement de de faire un espace il
n'était pas élu député de faire un
espace où ils arrivaient justement à
travailler certains votaient des choses
que d'autres n'acceptaient pas mais
voilà c'était pas le pugilat non plus au
sein du groupe ça arrivait vous le
reconnaissez juste d'un mot
Mélenchon c'était une stratégie y
compris qu'on a discuté qu'on a discuté
jour après jour de dire qu'on assume
d'avoir un levier par rapport au rythme
de la discussion et je crois qu'on
l'avait par ailleurs expliqué
quand vous avez fait bien avant le débat
sur la triple 7 quand vous avez dit vous
mettez beaucoup d'avant donc c'est pas
quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon fait un tweet
que tout d'un coup on sait Olivier
perron
le rendez-vous le rendez-vous des coins
ça a été assez fin des coïncidence
c'était assez étonnant vis-à-vis du
tweet de Jean-Luc Mélenchon aujourd'hui
si on parle parce que Sandrine Rousseau
et c'était d'ailleurs dans cette
séquence je trouve la phrase la plus
intéressante de la séquence c'est que ça
actait
la fin d'un acte 1 de l'anus donc il
faut un acte de mais quelle est cet acte
2 de la nuque visiblement aux yeux des
écologistes aux yeux des socialistes et
aux des communistes c'est un acte 2 avec
moins de Jean-Luc Mélenchon moins de
tweet de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et moins
présence de Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais le
problème
c'est un peu moins de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
je pense en tout cas qu'il y a ce besoin
aujourd'hui
il était avant il y a besoin en tout cas
d'acte je pense une évolution de ce
qu'on a envie de faire pas uniquement
une question c'est pas une question
d'incarnation moi c'est là où peut-être
je ne vous rejoins pas c'est pas
uniquement une question d'incarnation
c'est une question d'objectif politique
et moi ce que je crois et c'est pour ça
que on est engagé en politique c'est
qu'il faut changer la vie des gens et
pour changer la vie des gens il faut
gagner une élection et aujourd'hui si on
veut que la gauche gagne et ben oui il
va falloir qu'on avance dans peut-être
plus de construction commune sur aussi
des évolutions dans nos pratiques et
accepter aussi que peut-être l'hégémonie
elle n'est pas naturelle et que par
moment il faut que certains partis
soient plus forts se reconstruisent
assume des prises de position et pour ça
je pense que on a besoin de faire en
sorte que la nups on a construit en juin
dernier ne soit pas abîmé mais par
certaines prises de position c'est que
tout le monde a refusé la proposition de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui était de faire un
seul et même groupe donc une seule et
même machine et aujourd'hui il parle de
faire une corporation justement de d'un
organisme plus grand que les parties et
tout le monde dit non non surtout pas et
parce qu'on a chaque fois
un acte 2 de la nuque alors l'acte 2 de
la nuque ce qui est intéressant je
m'adresse Antoine brestiel mais vous
êtes à l'intérieur donc vous allez nous
dire il y a pas que les partenaires qui
se posent cette question il y a aussi
les insoumis Clémentine au thym le dit
texto dans Libération on est sur une
ligne de crête est-ce qu'on veut
galvaniser les nôtres ou est-ce qu'on
veut aller au-delà c'est-à-dire élargir
à un électorat qui n'est pas notre cible
première ça ça veut dire que le débat
voilà il travaille y compris chez les
insoumis c'est bien que ces questions se
posent et qui est des discussions qui se
qui se passent autour de ces questions
là mais ça rejoint je pense le point
qu'on soulevait juste avant le côté
clivant de de Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce
que c'est exactement sur sur ce point
Jean-Luc Mélenchon hors période
électorale ou dans les périodes
électorales il arrive à rassembler
beaucoup plus en partant finalement
assez bas et en terminant quand même
extrêmement haut à chaque élection mais
hors période électorale la tendance un
peu à se rétrécir sur seulement une base
qui est moins importante que que dans
les périodes électorales parce que
justement il peut il peut être paraître
beaucoup plus clivant dans ces périodes
là que dans les moments de campagne où
la population est aussi besoin beaucoup
plus galvanisée beaucoup plus prête à
entendre un message plus politique
forcément son objectif en fait c'est pas
forcément son objectif mais en tout cas
ce qui se passe à ce moment là c'est que
oui il y a une question qui se pose sur
la façon dont elle est FID doit se
comporter se comporte avec les autres
partenaires de la nups et justement ça
se cristallise dans la personnalité de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon pardon et dans sa
façon de pouvoir parfois avoir un propos
qui peut déplaire parce que trop brut
Daniel obono est-ce que au fond ce vote
que vous avez décidé sans Jean-Luc
Mélenchon aujourd'hui de réintégrer AD
c'est pas une manière tout simplement
d'insulter les partenaires qui ont tous
dit qu'ils ne souhaitaient pas qu'il
réintègre le groupe insoumi et donc
l'intergroupe de la nuque non parce que
d'abord je pense que il faut c'est deux
niveaux je suis pas sûr que ce soit très
juste et que ça aide à comprendre la
dynamique de l'anpece de mettre tout au
même niveau comme ça a été fait en
parlant Martin projet c'est la même
chose que on a parlé de l'élection dans
l'Ariège donc c'est quand même deux mais
là je vous pose la question on a un
sujet sur la question de comment on gère
les violences sexuelles et sexistes pas
simplement dans LFI d'avoir les filles
on y confronté mais dans toutes les
formations politiques dans les
formations syndicales dans la société
voilà et c'est vrai que pour notre part
on a beaucoup tâtonnets on sait pas que
ce soit dans le groupe ou dans le
mouvement l'intégration personnellement
moi j'ai participé au vote et si vous
avez voté la réintégration moi je dirais
pas ce que j'ai voté parce que je refuse
de mettre en porte-à-faux qui que ce
soit d'autre je sais pas respect de ce
vote collectif des décisions collectives
je crois que ça n'a pas d'intérêt de
dire telle à vos Tessie etc et on va on
va opposer les uns les autres et on va
refaire le débat et les retraits publics
à l'Assemblée une véritable affaire là
c'était là c'était un interrogé un vote
où chacun c'est c'est à donner son point
de vue on a beaucoup travaillé avec pas
beaucoup d'outils parce que on a peu
d'outils sur cette question là qu'est-ce
qu'on fait des personnes voilà qui ont
commis un acte sont condamné
purge leur purge leur peine vont au bout
de leur sanction qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
est-ce qu'on les aime pas que vous
électeurs ont envie de savoir si vous
avez voté je pense que ce débat là les
questions nous on a apporté une réponse
qui est peut-être pas satisfaisante pour
tout le monde on est critiqué et s'écrit
tes câbles tout à fait moi j'entends
mais est-ce que l'intérêt c'est pas de
se faire ce débat de dire qu'est-ce
qu'on fait est-ce qu'on exclut les gens
à jamais combien de temps les exclu
c'est des vrais questions très concrètes
et nous on se les ai pour vous je finis
la payer si j'ose dire condamnation il a
fait un stage dans une association ça
fait plusieurs mois on avait d'abord
commencé ce travail quand on a décidé
l'exclusion parce qu'on a décidé une
exclusion par rapport aux actes donc
c'était aussi posé un acte on s'est
exprimé là dessus et vous avez voté pour
servir l'intégration parce que vous avez
un argumentaire très ce que j'export sur
le sujet que j'essaie d'expliquer c'est
le processus d'un travail collectif sur
une question sensible qui traverse tout
le monde et ensuite par rapport pour
répondre à votre question sur
l'intercoupe de la nups je pense que les
termes des de nos partenaires ont été
posées notamment dans l'expression du
Parti socialiste et ces termes-là on les
connaît ça avait été déjà dit lors de de
son exclusion et donc ça je pense que ça
ne posera pas de problème stratégique ou
de remise alors on va demander je ne le
crois socialiste parce qu'on l'intervons
le fond et marafovic moi je circulais on
passe à autre chose moi je suis très
heurté par par cette décision
aujourd'hui
parce que les parties de gauche sont
encore beaucoup de travail à faire en
réalité pour engager cette transition
féministe et et c'est vrai on tâtonne
chacun prend des décisions chacun
prend
ses responsabilités mais c'est là où moi
je pense que parce que justement je suis
très attachée à l'union de la gauche
parce que je suis très attaché à la
nupesse je pense sincèrement que cette
décision nous fragilise moi je suis très
attaché à tout ça et vous fragile
je n'ai pas envie d'être aujourd'hui
tout à fait moi je pense que quand on
est féministe quand on est de gauche on
ne peut pas être représenté par
quelqu'un qui a été condamné pour
violence et c'est aussi simple que ça
après la question que vous avez posée
c'est est-ce que c'est une insulte aux
partenaires moi il y a ce que je ressens
en tant que responsable politique
socialiste mais en réalité tout ça est
très peu importe moi je pense que c'est
surtout une insulte pour les femmes que
c'est une insulte pour toutes les
féministes pour tous les féministes qui
aujourd'hui ont envie de voir une gauche
exemplaire dans les musiques de
l'Assemblée nationale et que si demain
nous voulons gagner et ben il va falloir
peut-être mettre un tout petit peu en
adéquation ce qu'on dit dans nos
programmes ce qu'on dit dans nos slogans
et ce qu'on fait ensuite dans les
assemblées et ailleurs je voudrais
terminer rapidement ce débat par la
question de la démocratie interne au
sein de la fille il y a un vote mais on
connaîtra pas votre vote il a pu y avoir
des réorganisations internes des
instances sans démocratie qui était très
critiquée par les partenaires et puis il
y a la question 2027 une primaire de la
nuque est-ce que ça c'est possible j'y
crois pas pour plusieurs raisons parce
que déjà Jean-Luc Mélenchon
conchit les primaires le format parce
que les socialistes ont été victimes il
y a d'autres il y a d'autres alors oui
l'option privilégier visiblement
aujourd'hui je ne vois pas quel
personnage politique à gauche à les
épaules pour venir
chatouiller Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais en
tout cas il y a une union une espèce de
cartel non non mais il y a un cartel en
face
l'objectif c'est de gagner donc on a
face à nous Macron
lui on est convaincu que c'est lui le
meilleur et en tout cas il y a un cartel
aujourd'hui ce qu'on observe c'est qu'il
y a un cartel de gens
notamment au sein de la nupes qui ne
veulent pas y compris au sein de LFI on
peut penser à Alexis Corbière on peut
penser à François Ruffin qui se pose la
question de savoir si l'option Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est la meilleure et leur
réponse elle est quasiment trouver c'est
de dire que non et ces gens-là discutent
beaucoup avec Olivier fort avec les
écologistes qui en sont déjà convaincus
et eux réfléchissent à des nouveaux
formats aujourd'hui qui sont du type ce
que font les juridics aux États-Unis
c'est à dire qu'on a un nombre impair et
on s'élimine au fur et à mesure jusqu'à
ce qu'il n'en reste qu'un et celui-ci
est le candidat ou alors l'autre option
c'est un comité des sages pour désigner
avec des personnalités politiques et
extrapolitiques pour désigner le
candidat en 2027 qu'il soit candidat
juste d'un mot Daniel mono c'est
vraiment une racine poignée de seconde
Jean-Luc Mélenchon oui je souhaite qu'on
gagne parce que le pays en a besoin et
je souhaite que la personne qui
représentera toute cette gauche et toute
la nuit pêche soit celle qui n'aurait
pas ma mère
mais des sondages 3 sur 4 montrent qu'on
peut être au deuxième tour notamment
avec la candidature de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais pour la nupes et donc je
pense que c'est ça que chacun et chaque
c'est clair Antoine Bressel il y a un
vrai espace s'il y a un candidat unique
de la gauche en 2027 il y a un espèce il
y a un candidat unique de la gauche en
tout cas plus que si que ce que s'il y a
une des unions de la gauche à ce
moment-là mais franchement faire des
prévisions sur ce qui va se passer de
d'ici 2027 qui va être le candidat d'une
possible l'Union etc enfin il y a
tellement d'eau qui va couler sous les
ponts d'ici là que c'est vraiment
beaucoup trop tôt pour se poser cette
question là on s'arrête là merci merci
beaucoup d'être venu débattre
malheureusement on n'a pas réussi à
mettre un membre de la nuque face à un
critique de la nuque mais c'était à
débat tout à fait tout à fait riche ce
soir Merci à VOUS Eugénie Bastié vous
restez avec nous dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties pris de nos
affranchis vous dévoyez ce soir
l'économie avec Fanny guinochet qui se
désole du rendez-vous manqué de la
majorité sur le grand âge le regard
européen de Richard vernis sur le tollé
occidental après le faux pas d'Emmanuel
Macron sur ta ïwan et puis dans Bourbon
Express ce soir Stéphanie Despierres
nous raconte les romous à l'assemblée
qui a suscité la tribune ce matin dans
votre journal Le Figaro j'ai dit Bastien
ou quelques députés à l'air plaid pour
que l'un des leurs soit nommé à Matignon
mais d'abord sauver la différence des
sexes c'est cette collection coup de
poing tracts chez Gallimard que vous
avez choisi Eugénie Bastié parce que
cette différence est menacée à vos yeux
on va voir ça dans l'invitation signée
Tibo Enok et on en parle juste après
si on vous invite Geny Bastié c'est que
nous ne savons plus très bien qui nous
sommes homme femme j'enrée non j'enré
préférant le bleu ou le rose c'est vrai
que nous sommes un peu perdus
heureusement on peut compter sur vous
pour remettre les pendules à l'heure à
l'heure de l'emoji homme enceinte du des
gens rage des barbecues et des Lego et
du trans comme nouvelle figure
iconique de la Révolution planétaire il
semble qu'il faille défendre la
différence des sexes Eugénie Bastié la
journaliste éditorialiste et essayiste
que vous êtes jeune garde de la droite
intellectuelle française défend ainsi à
longueur d'ouvrage ce que vous appelez à
un retour au réel et au bon sens on
assiste à un retour d'une bon sens non
un homme n'est pas une femme je crois
pour ma part que c'est toute notre
civilisation occidentale qui a besoin de
retrouver ce sens des limites un bon
sens conservateur qui vous a valu d'être
affublé de l'étiquette d'antiféministes
en particulier pour votre prise de
position lors du mouvement MiTo je m'y
riche contre la
victimisation excessive la main en face
n'a jamais tué personne dans votre
dernier ouvrage vous vous emportez cette
fois contre la théorie du genre et la
philosophe Judith Butler qui affirme que
l'identité sexuelle est une construction
sociale un mouvement de pensée qui a vos
yeux détruit tous nos repères et promeut
un nouveau modèle qui ressemble à un
grand désordre humain le supermarché des
identités est ouvert ou à don peut
choisir son visage ses dons mais aussi
son sexe son orientation sexuelle dans
des combinaisons aussi infinies que le
menu d'un fast-food un menu pas de votre
goût et qui relèverait même du gavage
affirmez-vous la fabrique du cuir
possède sa dimension autoritaire les
garçons ne se mettent pas spontanément à
jouer aux poupées ni les filles à
devenir pompier il faut détruire il faut
inculquer un grand coup de propagande la
déconstruction
dans ce mouvement vous estimez
d'ailleurs que les hommes sont désormais
les plus à plaindre eux dont tous les
repères sont mis à mal alors Eugénie
Bastié une question pour finir dans ce
grand trouble sur le genre à quoi nous
raccrocher
réponse j'ai dit Bastille au réel tout
simplement parce que de toute façon la
différence de sexe existe et elle
existera toujours quand je dis qu'elle
est menacée c'est pas qu'elle est
menacée biologiquement en tout cas nous
resterons des hommes et des femmes comme
dit la chanson boys Bill boys mais je
pense que effectivement le réel est
toujours là mais nous avons déconstruit
ce qui se greffe à cette différence qui
existe la différence culturelle et c'est
ça qui m'inquiète alors dans ce débat
idéologique les mots sont très
importants je dirais même qu'ils sont
cruciaux il faut bien comprendre de quoi
on parle d'abord vous ne vous opposez
pas à l'idée que le genre le masculin et
le féminin puisse circuler d'un sexe à
l'autre ça vous l'admettez vous
considérez par contre d'ailleurs vous
raconter que enfant vous étiez garçon
manqué que vous vouliez plutôt le
costume du prince que celui de la
princesse pas de difficulté avec vos
parents qui vous ont habillés en prince
voilà tout à fait jeûner une famille
plutôt de droite conservatrice donc
ça fait à l'époque on m'a pas proposé de
changer de le sexe justement c'est la
différence mais vous vous opposez en
revanche à l'idée que la différence des
sexes puissent être puisse être pensé
comme construite alors expliquez-nous
vous qu'est-ce qu'il y a d'irréductible
selon vous dans cette différence des
sexes oui je crois tout à fait
évidemment on ne n'est pas en rose et en
bleu on ne n'est pas avec avec des
petites voitures dans les bras et des
poupées évidemment il y a une différence
qui est construite et qui qui change
selon les civilisations selon l'attitude
selon le temps aussi on n'a pas la même
vision aujourd'hui la femme qu'on
l'avait il y a plusieurs siècles
simplement il y a une différence
irréductible biologique qui existe
la différence biologique alors il y a
une différence réelle ça personne pour
moi le fondement de la différence de
sexe c'est la maternité le fait que la
femme engendre dans son propre corps et
le corps et l'homme engendre dans le
corps d'autrui et c'est pas juste une
petite différence c'est pas juste comme
une robe qu'on suspendrait au vestiaire
c'est une différence qui nous habite qui
nous qui nous construit aussi et je
crois qu'on peut pas la mettre de côté
et que je reproche mouvements féministe
d'avoir nié finalement ce qui constitue
la féminité en disant finalement la
femme on la met en avant on veut mettre
des femmes partout mais en même temps la
femme ça n'existe pas on est incapable
de la définir moi je la définis
simplement la femme c'est celle qui peut
qui portent l'enfant et ça veut pas dire
qu'on est réduit à ce destin là c'est
une c'est un prix là on est encore dans
une alors Privilège vous dites même ce
terme parce que c'est pas moi c'est
celui de Françoise Héritier la grande
entreprise et qui qui parle du privilège
exorbitant de la maternité effectivement
qui est un mais qui n'est pas une
construction sociale et c'est ça qui me
qui me
hérissent dans un certain discours
d'idéologie du genre qui consiste à dire
alors en fait dire non seulement en fait
toute différence des sexes est
construite il n'y a pas finalement de
substrat réel à la différence des sexes
tout est une construction et en plus
parce que c'est construit il faut le
déconstruire et moi je dis non non
seulement tout n'est pas construit mais
en plus même si c'est construit il faut
pas forcément le déconstruire oui mais
la possibilité de porter un enfant
d'engendrer d'enfanter
elle est aussi biologique vous dites
quand même qu'il y a des différences qui
vont au-delà du biologique vous parlez
d'une sélection naturelle depuis elle
est la préhistoire les mâles plus forts
physiquement l'emporte dans la conquête
des femelles et développe je vous cite
agressivité goût du risque et appétit
sexuel sur quoi vous vous fondez pour
dire cela alors moi je me fonde déjà sur
toute une littérature scientifique et il
est évident qu'il existe des différences
entre les hommes et les femmes du point
de vue de la sexualité du point de vue
de la reproduction et du point de vue
même de l'agressivité de la violence et
moi je ne crois pas que ce soit une pure
construction sociale c'est aussi lié à
des siècles et des siècles d'évolution
et quand certaines féministes le pensent
certaines féministes ont été dans
l'évolution il y a de la construction on
a l'impression que c'est quasiment inné
dès la naissance je pense qu'en tout cas
il y a une il y a un rapport à la
violence à la sexualité qui ne dépend
pas que des conditions de socialisation
qui sont aussi en effet effectivement on
peut le dire inné ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas lutter contre il faut je
sais pas parce que c'est naturel qu'il
faut s'y résigner encore une fois mais
je pense qu'on peut pas comment dire
quand j'entends par exemple certaines
féministes qui disent que le viol est
une construction sociale je sursaute
parce que non le viol n'est pas une
construction sociale c'est une elle
refuse de dire que c'est une pulsion
mais effectivement c'est dire que c'est
un que c'est une violence comment dire
qui est propre à l'homme ça veut pas
dire de s'y résigner ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas être derrière faire un
travail pour éloigner pour domination
mais simplement s'il y a une réplique du
viol il faut de toute façon de protéger
les victimes je sais que c'est pas une
expression qui vous qui vous correspond
le plus intéressant me semble-t-il dans
cet essai c'est quand toutes ces
théories de la déconstruction que vous
combattez deviennent politiques
deviennent idéologiques et deviennent
même autoritaire voire violente exemple
je moi je mérite si vous voulez contre
la politique de l'intime qui consiste à
rentrer à l'intérieur des familles à
l'intérieur des foyers pour essayer de
dicter comment les gens doivent éduquer
leurs enfants quel rôle doivent être
assignés à la mer au père et si vous
voulez moi je considère les féministes
actuels ce que je le reproche c'est de
prôner finalement finalement la
différence dans le public en disant la
femme doit être il faut de la parité à
l'Assemblée nationale dans les médias
etc et l'égalité dans le public dans le
privé là dans le foyer dans la dans la
vie domestique moi je prône l'inversion
je prône l'égalité absolue dans le
public tout le monde a droit d'avoir
accès au même chat par contre qu'on
puisse cultiver la différence entre le
privé notamment dans les rôles sexuels à
l'intérieur du foyer je refuse que cette
ingérence de l'État cette espèce
d'ingénierie sociale qui consiste dès la
petite enfance à rééduquer pour essayer
d'en faire entrer au forceps alors c'est
pas l'état c'est plutôt le poids le
poids de certaines
sociologue mais
ça infuse dans la culture et par exemple
je le raconte moi je m'étonne j'ai deux
petits garçons je m'étonne par exemple
du manque de modèle masculin qu'on offre
au petit garçon on va venir sur la
question du malaise des hommes et je il
y a une culture qui ne prône que la
déconstruction envers la masculinité et
que la positivité envers la féminité je
m'étonne de ce yetus
le dévoilement de la déconstruction
pourquoi pas mais ça va pas devenir
l'impératif de la déconstruction est-ce
que c'est Judée de Butler pour vous la
plus la plus dangereuse celle qui aurait
à cause d'elle au fond heureusement tout
le monde ne lit pas jeudi Butler c'est
très difficile à lire la différence de
sexe c'est assez jargonnant mais
effectivement elle a poussé jusqu'au
bout ce paradigme disons de la
construction sociale puisqu'elle elle
elle considère que même la biologie est
une construction sociale et que le sexe
en soi n'existe pas et qu'en fait c'est
juste une manière qu'on a de désigner ce
qu'on a entre les gens mais qu'en fait
c'est ce n'est pas ça n'est pas un réel
biologique elle est elle est très très
loin là-dedans mais je pense que ça
infuse dans la société à plein de
niveaux par exemple je prenais l'exemple
des productions par exemple pour enfants
hollywoodienne ou Walt Disney par
exemple qui ne prône aujourd'hui que
qu'une vision déconstruite de ces de ces
de ses rapports entre mes femmes et par
exemple des exemples
de figures féminines rebelles guerrières
j'ai pas aucun problème qu'on prône
petite fille de
d'autres modèles que la princesse sache
très bien même si je pense qu'on a un
peu caricaturé le passé à ce niveau là
mais aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de
modèles pour les petits garçons on
déconstruit systématiquement les modèles
masculins et on offre que des modèles
féminins donc la féminité est sans cesse
à coller à une forme de positivité c'est
le pouvoir féminin le pouvoir des femmes
etc et la masculinité sans cesse à
coller à quelque chose de négatif la
masculinité toxique il faut des
construire vraiment on en est là Harry
Potter par exemple voilà un exemple pour
les petits garçons justement la
créatrice d'Harry Potter a de grosses de
grosses envahies
et elle s'est pris justement des
critiques de ses propres acteurs à
laquelle elle a tout donné c'est
lamentable mais alors est-ce que on en
est là aussi en France parce que ce que
vous décrivez ça existe aux États-Unis
ou certains sont obligés de décliner
leur appartement sexuelle en disant je
suis
6 Jean je suis privilège blanc je m'en
excuse etc on le voit à l'université on
le voit dans certains d'un certain film
dans certaines plateformes mais est-ce
qu'on en est là vraiment aujourd'hui
est-ce que les normes hétérosexuels sont
si menacées honnêtement je pense qu'en
France on est un peu protégés par notre
culture déjà on est culture très forte
de la mixité des sexes depuis toujours
c'est à dire qu'on a toujours été
mélangé dans l'espace public même si
évidemment il y avait des inégalités
mais les hommes étaient ta femme étaient
mélangés dans l'espace public et ce qui
fait la richesse je pense de notre notre
culture française là où dans les pays
plutôt anglo-saxons
de culture protestante et bien il y a eu
il y avait plus une séparation notamment
en Angleterre puis aux États-Unis et
donc je trouve que effectivement on a un
rapport plus complexe entre les sexes et
beaucoup de féministes françaises l'ont
étudié que la simple rivalité que la
simple guerre des sexes je crois qu'il
faut le préserver et le cultiver
exactement les mentalité on a une espèce
de rapport peut-être moins moins dur en
trois femmes avec une certaine
complicité une certaine complémentarité
et je crois que justement on a beaucoup
de féministes de la jeune génération qui
disent la France est en retard moi je
crois plutôt qu'on en avance alors
justement parlons des hommes parce que
ça c'est aussi un des volets de ce petit
essai gros malaise manifestement pour
les pour les hommes vous par de vos fils
les petits garçons depuis me too mais
pas seulement depuis toutes ces théories
de la déconstruction à part bien sûr le
mari de Sandrine Rousseau qui lui est
pleinement
déconstruit en retard à l'école
minoritaire à l'université majoritaire
chez les chômeurs addict à la
pornographie qu'elle tableau pour les
hommes ça fait peur vous écrivez les
hommes ont perdu leur rôle sans en
gagner de nouveau oui on en est là oui
mais je alors évidemment dès que je dis
ça on me dit on parle des statistiques
sur le viol sur les féminicides etc je
ne les nie pas évidemment mais je trouve
que on ne parle pas aussi de de ce qui
des inégalités qui touchent les hommes
et qui sont aujourd'hui de plus en plus
présentes parce que si on prolonge les
courbes et bien on s'aperçoit que il y a
de plus en plus de les femmes sont
majoritairement diplômées il y a moins
de chômage chez les femmes il y a toute
une série d'inégalités qui touchent les
hommes ils sont en retard à l'école les
petits garçons en moyenne un an de
retard sur les dans les pays de l'OCDE
et ça va jusqu'à 3 ans entre une fille
une petite fille des classes aisées et
un petit garçon des classes populaires
et donc ça c'est des inégalités il faut
je pense qu'on est parfois trop obsédé
par les problèmes du passé on ne voit
pas les nouveaux les nouvelles
inégalités les nouveaux problèmes qui
surgissent et la crise de la masculinité
en fait partie et je pense qu'il faut la
traiter parce que si par exemple dans ce
qu'on appelle le backlash son retour du
bateau conservateur qui adore la figure
de Trump qui a autorisé aussi avec moi
je sexiste avec ses accusations
d'agression sexuelle ce qu'on peut voir
sur les réseaux sociaux aux États-Unis
pour vous c'est quoi c'est le résultat
du malaise qu'on a mal je m'inquiète
justement d'un masculinisme qui serait
un peu le contre-pied du féminisme et je
ne veux surtout pas ça je ne veux pas
pour moi la virilité ça n'a rien de
caricatural c'est pas quelqu'un qui a un
homme qui se lève de la fonte et qui
boit de des protéines c'est bien plus
subtil que ça pour moi la vérité c'est
red Butler n'importe le vent c'est le
chevalier à table ronde c'est le vieil
homme et la mère de mingway c'est c'est
des figures multiples qui incarnent une
forme de prise de risque de force de
sagesse aussi et je ne voudrais pas que
ce soit caricaturer et justement je
pense qu'il
bienvenue les affranchis Richard Berly
du quotidien suisse Blic bonsoir
l'économie avec Fanny guenochet tous les
matins sur France Info à tout de suite
on commence bien sûr comme chaque soir
par le bourbon Express l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée nous est racontée par
Stéphanie des pierres bonsoir Stéphanie
bonsoir Stéphanie bonsoir décidément non
décidément c'est l'histoire d'une
tribune publiée dans Le Figaro
l'histoire surtout sans fin des
républicains qui cherchent toujours leur
place dans ce paysage politique très
éclaté dans le texte publié ce matin
trois députés les républicains et une
ancienne vice-présidente du parti
Virginie Calmels militent carrément pour
que Emmanuel prenne un premier ministre
de droite dans leur camp
pourquoi voulez-vous un premier ministre
les républicains on veut surtout sortir
de l'impasse politique dans lequel la
France est plongée une situation de
crise au pluriel qui permet qui permet
rien pourquoi vous pensez que ça irait
mieux avec un premier ministre les
républicains on pense surtout que faute
de majorité absolue et c'est le choix
des électeurs il faut trouver une
nouvelle articulation donc par
l'intermédiaire de cette tribune on pose
le débat d'une coalition sur un projet
nouveau qui correspond aux aspirations
des Français pendant les quatre ans qui
restent dans les signataires il y a donc
Stéphane Viry qu'on vient d'entendre
nicolas Forissier député de l'Inde mais
c'est une initiative de Philippe Juvin
médecin député des Hauts-de-Seine est
connu pour être plutôt macro
incompatible en fait cela fait une
dizaine de jours que cette tribune est
en préparation tout le monde ou presque
regroupait l'air était au courant
l'avait même atterri sur le bureau du
patron Olivier Marleix hors micro un
parlementaire pas forcément hostile à
une coalition tant pourtant ses
collègues le moment est mal choisi être
c'est ridicule si on veut faire bouger
les choses il faut être 15 ou 20 alors
finalement ils ne sont que 3 cette
tribune va donc faire cheat d'autant que
ce n'est pas la ligne de la majorité du
groupe et encore moins de ses dirigeants
écoutés
est-ce qu'il faut un premier ministre
les résultats
hors de question
c'est pas du tout à l'ordre du jour donc
je suis un petit peu étonnée c'est pas
la méthode qu'on a choisi les
républicains doivent rester indépendants
pas la même politique que celle du
président de la République n'avoir
absolument rien à faire ensemble Olivier
Marleix le patron a du groupe les
républicains que vous venez d'entendre à
donc redis non à notre micro et ce matin
en réunion deux groupes et avant vous
aviez entendu à Virginie dubitmüller
Maxime minot Emilie Bonivard alors
pourquoi cette tribune si personne n'en
veut pour lancer le débat disent ces
auteurs enfin plutôt le relancer je vous
rappelle que sur la réforme des
retraites les députés les républicains
sont très divisés certains sont pour
notamment le patron du groupe et du
parti d'autres contre et 19 députés ont
même voté la motion de censure contre le
gouvernement depuis on a mis la tête
dans le sable déplore un signature de la
tribune qui veut donc crever l'accès
crever l'abcès pardon par les des sujets
qui fâchent et de la suite cette
question Myriam d'une coalition des
républicains avec Emmanuel Macron
régulièrement à droite elle s'est posée
avant la présidentielle après
rappelez-vous une poignée de députés les
républicains avaient franchi le Rubicon
pour rejoindre naissance avant les
Législatives c'est Nicolas Sarkozy qui
en avait été l'avocat assez tôt et puis
durant ce débat sur les retraites c'est
Rachida Dati et Jean-François Copé qui
sont rangés à cette idée mais elle reste
chez les députés très marginales car
beaucoup doivent leur élection à une
campagne très anti Macron alors bien sûr
tout ce groupe là va se retrouver le 3
mai pour un séminaire entre députés les
républicains objectifs échanger échanger
échanger dit-on dans l'entourage
d'Olivier marlex bref une espèce de
thérapie de groupe pour tenter une fois
de plus de fédérés un peu les 61 nuances
de droite qui siègent sur les bancs des
républicains ici à l'Assemblée ils ont
raison de s'opposer comme ça les
républicains toute forme de coalition
pas d'entrée au gouvernement encore
moins Matignon moi je crois que oui ils
ont raison de pas rejoindre le Titanic
parce que c'est vrai que la majorité
macroniste étant difficulté s'ils l'ont
pas rejoint au moment où elles étaient
ils summum j'allais dire de sa gloire et
de sa puissance le rejoint maintenant ce
serait signé la fin effectivement pire
que aujourd'hui déjà
la fenêtre de tir de 2027 pour moi en
tout cas stratégiquement je vois je
verrai pas trop le sens d'un Premier
ministre républicain Richard berlé on
enchaîne avec vous il était à la
Emmanuel Macron au premier jour de sa
visite d'État au Pays-Bas il est revenu
sur son idée qu'il martait de
souveraineté européenne d'une Europe
autonome il a été chahuté par des
étudiants à la fois à la veille d'une
nouvelle journée d'action sur des
retraites mais aussi après le tollé
susciter sur ces déclarations sur Taïwan
alors est-ce qu'il est encore audible
notre président de la République alors
la question est simple j'ai une Bastille
s'occupe de la section des bas au Figaro
on la connaît est-ce qu'il suffit de
prononcer un discours pour être entendu
est-ce qu'une idée devient réalité à
force de la répéter et est-ce que
surtout il est possible de se dédoubler
c'est-à-dire d'être le président de
toutes les ambitions à l'étranger et le
président de toutes les contestations
dans son propre pays alors Myriam le
dilemme ne d'Emmanuel Macron l'Européen
qui à nouveau est illustré par son
discours à l'université Nexus de La Haye
la capitale des Pays-Bas alors sur la
forme d'abord vous venez de le dire la
réponse elle est tombée dès les
premières minutes il était à peine monté
sur le podium face à l'assistance que le
chahut a commencé à lancer pas un chahut
complet mais tout de même une banderole
est tombée des sièges du balcon Macron
président de la violence à l'évidence il
y avait quelques étudiants français dans
leur vie théâtre c'était clair une
poignée d'étudiants avait préparé le
coup le président s'en est bien sorti il
est resté calme en anglais il a évoqué
la liberté de parole en démocratie mais
quand même ce soir en ce moment même il
y a un dîner d'État qui est offert par
le roi vilaine Alexander des Pays-Bas on
imagine un peu les conversations autour
de la table et l'autre nuage on le
connaît c'est Taïwan évidemment
évidemment alors vous savez qui Emmanuel
Macron aime transgresser on sait aussi
que la France dans son histoire on pense
au général de Gaulle a toujours voulu
garder jalousement son autonomie
vis-à-vis des États-Unis mais pourquoi
avoir suggéré dans l'avion du retour de
Pékin à au quotidien Les Échos mais
aussi vos sites politico très influents
aux États-Unis que les Européens ne
doivent pas être suivis sur le sujet de
Taïwan au moment où des bateaux chinois
s'aventurent dans le détroit et surtout
que les Européens ne doivent pas
s'adapter au rythme américain ou à la
surréaction chinoise résultat le
discours de La Haye sur l'autonomie
européenne il est intervenu en pleine
polémique pas simple dans ces conditions
de convaincre sa même de l'UE parce que
la France et bien elle a besoin d'allier
figurez-vous depuis son discours de la
Sorbonne en 2017 Emmanuel Macron
réaffirme la nécessité d'une
souveraineté européenne il parle
ressources énergétique marché européen
réciprocité investissement technologies
aussi défense ce qui est en ce moment
avec le retour en force de l'Otan n'est
pas si simple mais le problème c'est
qu'à chaque fois le président a tendance
à confondre le jeu avec le nous il parle
au nom des Européens mais qui est avec
lui alors par exemple aujourd'hui
pourquoi La Haye le Premier ministre
néerlandais marcuté n'était pas assez
coté bref où sont les alliés de la
France pour faire de l'Union européenne
un faiseur de règles et non pas un
suiveur de règles dictée par d'autres
une jolie formule d'Emmanuel Macron à
cette question son discours
d'aujourd'hui n'a malheureusement pas
encore apporté de réponse
vous comprenez ce qu'il a pu dire sur
sur Taïwan la France puissance
d'équilibre à équidistance entre la
Chine et Taïwan comme si il n'était pas
dans le camp des démocraties non mais je
pense qu'il y a un sens à avoir ce
discours là effectivement ne pas obtenir
bloc après vous l'avez très bien dit
c'était le moment qui était très mal
choisi au moment où effectivement les
bateaux chinois étaient encerclé Taïwan
il aurait pu choisir un autre moment
après je pense qu'il a raison sur le
fond de vouloir tracer un sillon qui ne
soit pas exactement celui des Américains
nous avons encore les moyens mais en
tout cas il faut c'est sûr que si on ne
le dit pas on en aura encore moins les
moyens c'est à dire que déjà le dire
c'est affiché une une couleur et je
crois que c'est important de de
considérer en tout cas que nous avons
pas et c'est un film n'avons pas les
mêmes intérêts économiques politiques
géopolitique que les Américains vous
avez vu
si la France est à équid différence
entre Taïwan et la Chine nous on est
aussi très loin de l'Ukraine et on se
retire ils ont fait d'autres choix mais
ce sont leurs choix à eux et le jeu
dangereux
ils suivent aussi leurs intérêts on
continue avec vous pour terminer Fanny
Fanny guinochet vous vouliez nous parler
de cette proposition de loi qui est en
discussion ce soir dans l'hémicycle sur
le Bien Vieillir proposition de la
majorité Renaissance est un texte qui
doit répondre à l'énorme défi du
vieillissement et de la dépendance
promesse présidentielle mais franchement
pas à la hauteur ben écoutez oui parce
que vous l'avez dit c'est devoir
répondre normalement ce texte à au défi
du vieillissement et que c'est pas un
petit défi je rappelle les chiffres les
plus de 85 ans aujourd'hui c'est 2
millions de Français et à horizon 2050
ce sera 5 millions donc répondre à ces
dernières années de vie de retraite à
l'autonomie tout ça dans un texte qui se
cantonne à 14 petits articles alors par
comparaison juste comme ça le projet de
loi sur l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement de Marisol Touraine en
2015 c'était 66 articles alors bon 14
articles pourquoi pas mais quand même il
porte je cite sur la lutte contre
l'isolement des personnes âgées des
mesures contre la maltraitance
évidemment ça fait suite au livre de
Victor Castanet sur la maltraitance dans
les EHPAD l'idée c'est de créer aussi un
guichet unique pour aider les familles
ça reste quand même de grands
principales Renaissance se défend en
disant il vaut mieux une petite loi
efficace plutôt qu'une loi un texte
fourre-tout oui mais dans cette
proposition de loi il y a par exemple la
création d'une conférence nationale de
l'autonomie sur le modèle de la
Conférence nationale du handicap ça
ressemble quand même un grand raout et
un four tout bon alors les mesures
concrètes il y en pas dans cette
proposition pour le logement des seniors
mais bon ça va aller très très vite la
plupart des acteurs qui ont suivi le
dossier disent que cette loi finalement
est très déceptive les socialistes ont
d'ailleurs déposé une contre-proposition
beaucoup plus ambitieuse et la plupart
de ceux qui suivent ce dossier disent
que ça ne remplit pas ses ambitions le
gros problème quand on s'attaque à la
dépendance c'est l'argent le financement
c'est le nerf de la guerre parce que on
peut par exemple proposer un guichet
unique dans les territoires mais avec
quel argent c'est les collectivités qui
vont payer c'est l'état ce sont des
financements privés pourquoi pas comme
des assureurs que l'on pourrait mettre à
contribution et bien tout ça c'est
renvoyé à l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale de
2024 c'est-à-dire donc à l'automne donc
il n'y a pas de réponse alors certes à
sa décharge on pourra dire qu'Emmanuel
Macron a été le premier président à
créer la cinquième branche de la
sécurité sociale pour s'occuper
justement du grand âge qu'il en a aussi
augmenté le budget mais on sait aussi
que ça reste quand même parce que le
financement du grand âge ça n'est pas
ça se compte vraiment en milliard
d'euros on est à 10 milliards d'euros
par an dans les projections alors le
gouvernement dit que cette pppl est une
première pierre à un édifice dont on
posera les suivantes il y aura un plan
d'action qui sera présenté en mai juin
c'est-à-dire après la réforme des
retraites on va suivre ça
le grand âge devra attendre si j'ose
dire et en plus il y a rien de plus
prévisible que la démographie et
on a l'impression qu'on agit quand on
est pied du mur merci beaucoup on va
s'arrêter là merci Eugénie de Bastié
d'être passé sur le plateau LCP sauver
la différence des sexes chez Gallimard
c'est décapant très stimulants et ça
fait des débats j'en suis sûr autour des
des tables familiales entre les jeunes
et les aînés merci à vous c'est la fin
de cette émission très belle soirée
documentaire bien sûr qui commence avec
Jean-Pierre Graffin à demain
même heure
[Musique]